the world is a myriad of possibilities
from gene therapy to shape-shifting
robots to virtual reality and now
augmented reality 20 years ago it would
have been crazy to think we could have
combined real world and
computer-generated content or that we
would be able to operate computers with
nothing but a contact lens this is what
is known as augmented reality if you're
not a science nerd like me you may be
wondering what is augmented reality in
simple terms augmented reality or ar for
short is all about blending the real and
Virtual Worlds to create something
entirely new and exciting it's a
technology that allows us to enhance the
real world with digital content through
holographic technology enabling the
virtual to interact with the physical
environment okay think of it this way
while virtual reality wants reality
entirely in a digital world AR wants to
enrich our perception of the real world
by using computer-generated images video
sound and other details it's like
creating an entirely New Perspective of
reality for our brains so how does it
work inside any device that creates AR
content virtual 3D images can overlay
real-world objects based on their
geometrical relationship the device must
be able to calculate the position and
orientation of objects relative to
others so the combined image is
projected on mobile screens AR glasses
and other devices such as contact lenses
these AR contact lenses would serve as
the main talking point in this video but
first I would like to lay the groundwork
for how augmented reality came to be a
little history lesson everyone in 1968
the first AR technology was developed at
Harvard by Ivan Sutherland often called
the father of computer graphics and Bob
sprouli Sutherland and spruilly created
an AR head mounted display system to
superimpose virtual information onto the
physical environment this was called The
Sword of Damocles kinda cool in a punk
rock way this technology has then been
Advanced by come companies universities
labs and National agencies over decades
however it wasn't until 2008 that the
first commercial AR application was
developed German agencies in Munich
created a printed magazine ad for a BMW
Mini that appeared on the computer
screen when held in front of a camera by
manipulating the paper users could
control and view the virtual car from
different angles this was one of the
first marketing campaigns that allowed
interaction with a digital model in real
time this groundbreaking AR application
inspired other brands to put content on
a screen and have consumers interact
with it through physical tracking
markers in 2011 National Geographic
showcased rare and extinct animal
species walking through a shopping mall
in 2011 also Disney showed cartoon
characters interacting with people on
the street in Times Square while in 2013
Coca-Cola tried to simulate
environmental problems these AR displays
were used to engage customers at events
or public spaces but they required
considerable investment and weren't
always scalable still it's so clear that
since the early 2010s augmented reality
had already started taking off but the
real shift happened when AR usage left
just advertisement and started affecting
how we relate to and consume products
imagine virtually trying on a watch or a
piece of jewelry from the comfort of
your own home this technology was
groundbreaking at the time because it
gave customers a better sense of what a
product would look like on them before
they even purchased it even the Apple
watch was available for a similar
virtual try on this process wasn't
always perfect the task of printing out
and cutting a unique paper model to fit
one's finger or wrist was somewhat
clunky and required effort from the
consumer but that didn't stop people
from trying it out and having fun with
it fast forward a few years and the most
significant AR technology was introduced
to use in the form of a tiny contact
lens we're building Mojo lens which is
we believe the world's first augmented
reality smart contact lens a USD startup
called Mojo Vision has developed a
contact lens that delivers an augmented
reality display right in front of your
eyes that's right you can now get
information and notifications without
looking at your phone or tablet and not
just that you can interact with the
display using just your eye movement
think of it like a spotlight a spotlight
that follows your eyes wherever they
move and so it's about 15 degrees but
you can't look at the edges directly
because it moves with your eyes so we we
like to say it's an unlimited field of
view this breakthrough invention has
been in development for the last 10
years and has already received over 100
million dollars or 77 million pounds in
funding Mojo Vision CEO Drew Perkins
said Mojo has a vision for invisible
Computing where you have the information
you want when you want it and are not
bombarded or distracted by data when you
don't the company's goal is to reduce
our dependence on screens by putting the
display on our eye by projecting a micro
LED display play directly onto the
retina Mojo Vision has managed to create
a virtual teleprompter navigation
instructions and other interactions that
appear floating in your field of vision
the contact lens uses unique
purpose-built microelectronics and the
world's densest micro display with 14
000 pixels per inch resolution the heart
of the lens is the world's smallest and
densest micro LED display in the center
that's the thing in the center we had to
invent that ourselves so it's a half a
millimeter across with a density of 14
000 pixels per inch which is by far the
densest display you're ever going to
find the company has also developed a
solution that allows you to click on an
icon by concentrating on it and turn it
off by looking away or blinking the lens
is discreet and does not change your
appearance making it perfect for
professional and social situations the
Mojo Vision contact lens is even
connected to the internet which means
you can get instant access to
information based on your surroundings
Forex example it can show you the way to
the nearest gym or Supermarket also the
company has received approval from the
U.S Food and Drug Administration or FDA
as a breakthrough device to test the
contact lens to help people with visual
impairments such as macular degeneration
or retinitis Pigmentosa Mojo Vision
envisions business applications for
workers or Specialists who need
real-time information in their field of
vision without bulky headsets so get
ready to say goodbye to those clunky
headsets and hello to the Mojo Vision
contact lens the lens is not yet
available for commercial launch but with
the fda's approval it's only a matter of
time before we see this game-changing
invention in action Mike feimer a
co-founder at Mojo Vision had this to
say we think it's a really exciting new
category with a lot of opportunity if we
can kind of change the way we the
relationship that we have with some of
our screens and actually make things
less intrusive by letting us look and
feel human right our contact lens that
is is very subtle and hard to notice but
why does any of this even matter well
many in Silicon Valley believe that AR
will become as ubiquitous as smartphones
most experiments with ar have focused on
glasses or headsets in 2014 there was
Google Glass and apple glasses expected
to hit the market soon in addition a
variety of wearables are already
available on the market that incorporate
AR technology such as the Amazon Echo
frame vuzix blade upgraded and Ray-Ban
stories they tend to be heavy leaving
the wearers looking and feeling like
Jordy laforge from Star Trek that's why
Mojo vision went straight to a
hands-free and light option they are
making AR more discreet and consumer
friendly basically projecting the
visuals directly onto our retinas this
could significantly impact real-world
applications especially in Industries or
environments where the aforementioned
types of wearables are impractical a
good example is when riding a bike some
of the early use cases that we're
looking at are really focused on Sports
and athletic performance where you want
to have eyes up information when you're
running or skiing or cycling during any
seriously engaging Sports you need to be
aware of your surroundings you need to
ensure that you can look at the
information quickly and move on with
Mojo vision's contact lenses important
information can be easily overlaid
without getting in the way so why is
this such a big deal for starters it
could literally revolutionize the way we
receive and interact with information
think about it instead of pulling out
our phones or listening in on headsets
we could simply look into the corner of
our vision and see important
notifications or instructions basically
having a computer in the palm of your
hand or eye also Mojo vision's contact
lenses would be handy in professions
like medicine or engineering where
workers need to have access to real-time
information as fast as possible it would
be so cool for instance a surgeon seeing
their patients vitals in real time or an
engineer seeing hard to reach parts
inside a machine will definitely improve
job efficiency also though they can
potentially change the game for people
with poor vision and First Responders
alike these lenses can enhance images in
real time by adjusting contrast and
lighting making seeing details in low
light conditions easier but that's not
all there's even a zoom feature that can
help you see facial expressions from
afar how cool is that but the real magic
lies in how these lenses could be used
in high stress environments like
firefighting imagine being able to see
the outlines of objects in smoke-filled
rooms and track the locations of other
team members or without taking your
focus away from the task at hand the
lenses could even display your oxygen
levels without the user fumbling around
for a device I mean talk about a game
changer and it gets even better Mojo is
working on a version of The lenses for
the rest of us we'll have access to
location data weather updates and even
translations right in your line of sight
without pulling out your phone it's like
having an invisible computer or a
personal assistant right in your eyes we
can't wait to see what the future holds
for this exciting technology the
application and possibilities are
Limitless still it's rather ironic that
we've gone from not sitting too close to
the television to putting the television
on our eyeballs science is amazing
overall motovision's AR contact lenses
are an exciting development in the world
of wearable technology this is the stuff
that sci-fi dreams are made of still
there's a lot to do these lenses are
still in development and have some
regulatory hurdles to clear before they
hit the market even with FDA approval
there are questions like how would the
strain of these contact lenses affect
the eyes is there a risk of burns I mean
it's still an electrical Gadget how
would it affect those with poor eyesight
well I can't give you an answer to all
the questions but for the first question
there's an answer already you're not
going to have the display on full
brightness always active for for eight
hours or whatever it happens to be our
goal is about two hours of continuous
use but chunked up and spread out
throughout the day now let's discuss how
this lens works and the intricacies of
of it all we'll start from what we
already know and work our way down the
core of this technology is a micro
display positioned directly in front of
the pupil this is meant to mimic regular
contact lenses this micro display is
mighty with 14 000 pixels per inch
that's essentially 300 times more than
the average smartphone's 471 pixels per
inch however Mojo lenses are gas
permeable and rigid so they need to be
custom fitted to your eyes this means
that you can't go passing your lenses to
just about anyone they'll be specially
made for you a typical feature of hard
contact lenses now you may wonder how
would this contact lens even be powered
well Mojo claims that small film-like
batteries within the lenses will likely
power them and give or take they should
be good for a full day of use
Additionally the lens is powered by a
streaming computer worn around the neck
this would stream content at extremely
low latency via a proprietary
communication protocol directly to the
lens here is Steve Sinclair senior VP
product and marketing at Mojo explaining
it most of the compute does happen on a
another device we call it a relay
accessory it's like a neck band that you
wear around your neck it has a wireless
radio with that five gigahertz
connection so if you can talk to your
eyes talk to the lens
um it's got a CPU and a GPU and memory
and it's got radio so it can talk to
your phone this Innovative protocol
minimizes latency and conserves the
lenses batteries making it more
efficient and faster than Bluetooth
however it's unclear how this
communication will work because Mojo has
said it will not rely on Bluetooth but
instead on a proprietary technology
called Mojo tooth due to its secure
interference free transmission between
the neck and eye computer direct
streaming from smartphones or the cloud
is not currently possible the lenses
will also have an embedded image sensor
to recognize what you're looking at and
bring up contextual information that may
be helpful so eye tracking sensors will
also be included in the final version
helping the lenses follow your gaze Mojo
is working towards the next iteration of
these lenses which is expected to be
revealed soon but their biggest hurdle
is gaining total FDA approval which
could take several years of clinical
trials we'll be making tweets to all the
elements of the system to the UI
building out software and and building
out the the platform aspects of what we
want to do and then once we've done that
then we can take that finished product
to the FDA nevertheless the lenses have
been admitted into the Breakthrough
devices program which provides guidance
for getting them approved for medical
purposes but once these lenses hit the
markets they would genuinely disrupt the
ecosystem Mojo Vision doesn't see its
technology as a replacement for future
data glasses but wants to secure
significant shares of the Emerging
Market the startup predicts that 20 to
30 percent of smart glasses users could
prefer Tech contact lenses also the
company hopes to price the Mojo lens in
the high-end smartphone region but
purchasing the lens will be more
complicated than buying a smartphone
with only around a 110 employees and
raise capital of about 205 million
dollars motovision is considered a
relatively small and potentially
underfunded startup this makes it
challenging for them to scale up and
expand their operations the company is
looking to raise more funds to support
their growth one of the biggest barriers
to entry for the Mojo lens in the
consumer Market is that the lens needs
to be custom made for each user
additionally an external computer must
be worn around the neck to stream
content directly to the lens this could
pose a challenge for customers who are
looking for a more convenient and
user-friendly option however Mojo vision
is aware of these challenges and is
working on further refinement to make
their product more accessible to the
broader Market they are striving to find
innovative solutions to these problems
and we look forward to seeing what they
come up with Mojo is not the only one in
the smart contact lens game there's also
inner Vega however for innovega it's a
bit different they are already producing
smart glasses and contact lenses so the
hemacula system which includes both
contact lens and the eyewear has
displays located inside the eyewear with
the electronics to power the displays
and then a contact lens which enables
the user to see the displays inside the
eyewear while also seeing the real world
after extensive contract work for the US
government and Military innovaga has
been shifting its focus to the
commercial Market including developing
soft contact lenses that can be worn all
day like Mojo this Bellevue
washington-based company aims to use
contact lenses to create an augmented
world view in 2022 in a Vega
Incorporated made an impressive
breakthrough in smart contact lenses
during a phase 2 clinical trial the
company's ioptic smart contact lens
showed promising results in participants
who wore them with and without in a
Vegas high-tech eyeglasses the results
showed that the visually impaired
participants reported better visual
Acuity if perfected this technology will
help people who are visually impaired to
see the world like never ever before
this Milestone is a significant
achievement for the company founded
nearly 14 years ago in a Vegas CEO and
co-founder Stephen Wiley believes that
his company's patented technology
combining lightweight eyewear and
disposable soft contact lenses will
ultimately win over approaches that
require bulky headsets or low resolution
displays in a Vegas progress comes at a
perfect time when big players like meta
Microsoft and Apple are bringing new
attention to the metaverse with 20
people on its team including employees
and contractors innovager has generated
about 6 million dollars in Revenue over
its lifetime and has raised about 16
million dollars in funding including
three million dollars from its new
strategic partner and other corporate
Venture funds despite all the strides
there's still a lot that's not known
about in a Vega one example is the
identity of innovager's commercial
partner however the company expects to
receive regulatory approval soon with
phase 3 clinical trials currently
underway with the U.S food and Drug
Administration the commercial agreement
validates innovega's plan to license its
technology to other companies that will
manufacture and distribute the final
product if this happens this will push
in a Vega to the General market but hold
on before you get too excited we are
still years away from seeing these
contact lenses in our eyes why it all
comes down to three factors technology
medical approval and market value first
let's talk about technology the
electronics required for smart contact
lenses have to be incredibly tiny and
implementing them comes with several
challenges companies must carefully
consider which type of contact lens to
use as their base and build the
technology from there for example Mojo
Vision uses a scleral lens with all the
technology embedded inside the lens and
a wearable neck device as the processor
meanwhile innovaga uses a soft lens with
a polarizer filter that pairs with
glasses that handle most of the
technology each type of Contact Lens
comes with its own difficulties and the
manufacturing process can be time
consuming but with recent advancement
scleral lenses are becoming more popular
again we've identified that the best
contact lens platform to meet our need
is the scler lens platform in recent
years the red plans became more popular
again because they realized that now
it's easier to make After figuring out
the manufacturing issues the companies
had to make sure that their contact
lenses were gas permeable bio-compatible
and had Superior performance since these
smart contact lenses are considered
medical devices they must also be
approved by the FDA before clinical
trials the companies have to verify the
physical and chemical properties of the
lens material through multiple
pre-clinical tests if we're making the
claim then we have to prove we do that
you try to figure out if there is
anything that could be potentially
harmful currently both Mojo vision and
innovaga are in Phase 2 clinicals to
verify their designs and compare them to
other marketed lenses still it's not
just these two upcoming items that are
in the game in with Corp announced Tech
that could revolutionize the world of
contact lenses at the 2021 Consumer
Electronics Show or CES what's so
special about this technology you ask
well in with has developed soft contact
lenses that can house AR chips to
enhance the vision of everyday consumers
these chips are embedded into the
hydrogel and in with claims to be the
only company publicly demonstrating this
technology and they've got several
hundred patents to back it up their
ultimate goal is to create a contact
lens platform for the masses that can
improve daily Vision using augmented
reality and the best part in with plans
to receive breakthrough approval from
the FDA soon with plans of the contact
lens hitting the market shortly after
that's right this technology is no
longer a concept it's becoming a reality
there's a lot of things that people are
willing to do to improve their visual
experience and I think that once they
put on the lenses and they and they feel
that they are comfortable and that they
feel very much exactly like what they're
used to wearing then I think they'll
they'll realize that there's not a
boogeyman uh behind the lenses according
to Michael Hayes the founder of in with
the lens can superimpose information
from a connected device like a
smartphone directly into your field of
view imagine seeing speed limits
navigation arrows and other important
information without looking away from
your road or your surroundings that's
augmented Vision at its finest as if
that's not enough Apple reportedly plans
to release AR contact lenses by the
decades end Yes you heard that right
Apple according to Reliable Apple
analyst Ming Chi Kwo the company is
working hard to turn visible Computing
into invisible Computing and they're
doing this by creating lenses that can
do more than improve your vision but
wait there's a catch according to quo
these lenses will likely work in tandem
with your iPhone and won't have
independent storage for computing of
course this could change depending on
how the technology develops but still
the idea of having AR capabilities in
your contact lenses is interesting to
say the least technology is advancing so
quickly before our eyes traditional
lenses could soon be a thing of the past
it's exciting to think about how AR
contact lenses could make the world a
better and more interesting place from
creating smart cities to the uncountable
Integrations with the metaverse I mean
just think about it no phones GPS just
an eye movement and a voice command and
it's not just consumers who stand to
benefit AR contact lenses could also
revolutionize various Industries just
think of lawyers having access to
records in real time or construction
workers visualizing building plans right
in front of them with companies like
Mojo in with innovega and apple entering
the smart contact lens game the future
is exciting so as I end here let me ask
you a question would you wear a smart
contact lens when they inevitably get
released to the public thanks for
watching click on the videos you see on
your screen for more